lawsuit that was just filed by
congressman Devin Nunez against fusion
GPS that was the firm behind the
infamous steel dossier
now Nunez is alleging that fusion GPS
and the group campaign for
accountability worked on a joint and
systemic effort to intimidate harass
threaten influence interfere with and
impede ultimately derail Nunez is
investigation into Russian election
interference here now is a congressman
himself ranking member of the House
Intelligence oprima who I haven't
followed every iteration of this story
how did fusion GPS try to impede your
investigation well all people have to
Goo's go back to 2018 and if you
remember there were daily stories that
would be generated about how I had
leaked something I was under
investigation
I was obstructing an investigation well
those were all originating from these
ethics complaints that continued to be
filed by campaign for accountability so
what we ended up finding out is that of
the 1.2 million dollars that they raised
in 2018 a hundred and forty thousand
dollars over ten percent of the budget
went to fusion GPS two of the three
ethics complaints directly related to
fusion GPS only fusion GPS could have
given this to campaign for
accountability you know let's let's get
this straight campaign for
accountability they've been around for
about three or four years they are a
left-wing organization they attack
conservative Republicans on a daily
basis so if people want to clean up
politics only the courts are going to be
able to do this and so that's why we're
taking this to the third branch of
government the court system and we're
hopeful that the court will come in and
see this as a as a RICO racketeering
group look at congressman
look the left does this all the time
they run to the courts to try to thwart
the President's agenda they've done it
on immigration they did it on the travel
ban there's nothing that this
administration has tried to do of any
significance that the left hasn't tried
to stop in a courtroom so I think it's
great that you're out there and you're
trying to instill some sense of
accountability and transparency into
this whole process I think more
conservatives frankly should do what
you're doing and I also I gotta replace
something I got to replace moment from
the Muller hearing this summer where he
could not recall a very important piece
of the puzzle Watch quote the firm that
produced steel reporting unquote the
name of that firm was fusion GPS is that
correct and you're on page 103 103
that's correct volume 2 the name of the
firm that produced that was fusion GPS
is that correct I'm not familiar with
that it's not a trick question I mean it
was fusion GPS looks like a Joe Biden
answer on that one ha concerning was
that well there were a lot of answers
like that I mean clearly Moeller didn't
know what was in his own report and
that's why we have to bring these one of
the reasons why we need to continue to
bring these lawsuits Laure is to clean
up this mess
remember fusion gps has a long history
of doing this they did it to the Trump
campaign they did it to Bill Browder
people forget that these guys work for
the Russians they work for dirty
Russians they work for dirty Venezuelans
this is a group this this has to stop
and the only way it can stop is if is if
Republicans who are in who are in a
position to be able to bring these cases
against against these groups we have to
be able to do it congressman Nunez thank
you so much for being with us tonight